and tonight fox is confirming that three
white house officials will be headed to
capitol hill on thursday and not to
discuss ways to combat what you just
heard from peter schiff runaway
inflation but rather to discuss
a message strategy on the economy
fighting inflation and reducing costs
for the american people yes they think
it's a comms problem over at the white
house newt gingrich joins us former
speaker of the house fox news
contributor author of defeating big
government socialism
newt um
we said this a year ago they thought
that they they thought always think this
is a messaging problem when it's a
substance problem
that segment with peter schiff was
terrifying
things are going to get a lot worse and
they don't seem to care
well i say first of all at a personal
level
the more i've watched the last five or
six weeks the more i've worried about my
own
investment strategies what i'm doing in
terms of trying to save money uh where
to put it what's happening
i think it's really
an enormous enormous problem and the
average american knows it because they
go out and they buy gasoline or they go
to the store to buy food or they try to
find infant formula
you just go down the whole list
and i think for the white house to think
that this is not a substantive
real life problem
it's a sign of how totally out of touch
with everyday normal americans they are
and i think it's an enormous problem
now john kerry um probably off of fresh
freshly off a private jet
admits kind of that this was all
intentional watch
energy security worry is driving a lot
of the thoughts now about oh we need
more drilling of gas we need more
drilling in this we need to go back to
coal no we don't we're the second
largest emitter in the world
we bear a major responsibility and
president biden
believes that to the core
and he's determined that we're going to
do our part to make up for the last four
years
well most of america doesn't have the
heinz of wealth behind itself to so they
don't have to worry john's okay there on
his background but regular people hear
that they're probably heads exploding
look
well look i i think that
comment
tells you everything about why
uh the big government socialist model is
failing
and why the
democrats just don't have a clue here's
a guy who's extraordinarily wealthy
wind surfs off cape cod
goes around the world in a private plane
from four star hotel to four-star hotel
to eat in gourmet restaurant after
gourmet restaurant
and then he doesn't quite get it that if
you're a hard-working single mother or a
single father and you're out here every
day and you can barely afford
to pay for the gasoline to get to work
that maybe you're not sympathetic with
the ultra rich
and i think this is a real challenge for
the democrats because they basically are
shrinking into two groups left-wing
cuckoos like aoc
and people who are so wealthy they have
no connection to the real world and
those two groups get together and they
reassure each other
but out here for the rest of us
we just did a survey where we asked how
important is it to restore the america
that works 87 percent of the country
almost 9 out of every 10 americans said
restoring the america the works
is really important
that tells you that almost 9 out of 10
americans do not think america is
currently working and guess who's in
charge of not working joe biden all
right new great to see you tonight thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else